hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about chia seeds
amazing nutrients check this out it has
essential fatty acids very similar to
flax seeds and essential fatty acids are
the component that helps build your cell
the membrane of the cell the little tiny
things inside the cell they're called
organelles that that run the cell it has
more omega-3 than salmon it is five
times as much calcium five times more
calcium than milk
high fiber vitamin b2 b1 b3
it's niacin it has boron which actually
helps calcium make bone solid it also
has a certain type of fat called the
polyunsaturated fatty acids which which
basically ionizes calcium so it allows
calcium to go into the tissues deeper
and we'll talk about what that will do
in a second and then it has high protein
in one little tiny ounce it has four
point nine grams that's a lot of protein
so it's a really good source of
nutrients now you can also make this in
a like a pudding a cheat chia seed
pudding I'll put a rest recipe below but
I think the biggest benefit of Chi is
the essential fatty acids so what I want
to do is I'm going to talk about all the
things that are affected when you have
enough essential fatty acids and also
when you're deficient okay so it affects
you energy levels so endurance if you're
actually working out hard core workout
person and you consume chia seed you'll
spike the essential fatty acids and you
recover faster
why because essential fatty acids allow
the transportation of oxygen through
this system they allow the oxygen
exchange in your lungs they push the
oxygen into the hemoglobin into the into
the blood and basically help you recover
faster helping you stabilize blood
sugars the essential fatty acids help
postmenopausal so for estrogen issues
and also if you're deficient in
essential fatty acids your skin is going
to be flakey pili rough you know you see
people with like these flakes of skin
coming out of their like their ear or
their nose or their
their head that's basically an essential
fatty acid deficiency so you can consume
these or flax oil to get these to make
your skin real smooth strong nails if
you're deficient in this fatty acid
you're going to get ridged nails so we
got hair skin nails I talked about this
in other videos with B vitamin
deficiencies but the essential fatty
acids work with the B vitamins work with
the trace minerals all to make hair skin
and nail real really nice if you're
deficient in this fatty and I said you
can get charley horses why because we
talked about the ionization of calcium
calcium drives into deep into the
tissues and if you're deficient in that
you can get cramping sunburn why because
you need calcium to protect from excess
Sun you can literally take to your feeds
to enhance your essential fatty acids to
minimize sun burns and also if you
actually are sunburned to recover from
that consuming essential fatty acids
from this or flaxseed can actually help
you recover faster also will help put
herpes which is a virus back in
remission and also improves hypothyroid
because these essential fatty acids
potentiate iodine okay in the thyroid so
they they really help from a lot of
different angles alright so go ahead and
check out the recipes down below and
I'll talk to you soon press it forget it
forget it under press the subscribe
button and I will keep you updated on
the future event